استقلنا قطارًا إلى مدينة كيف
من جنوب غرب بولندا ، لذلك
لم نر الكثير باستثناء النظر إلى
نوافذ القطار في طريقنا إلى الداخل ،
وذهبنا مباشرة إلى
القصر الرئاسي بعد ساعات فقط من مغادرة وزيري الخارجية والدفاع للولايات المتحدة لأوكرانيا
دويت صفارات الإنذار في غرب
أوكرانيا ، قال رئيس السكك الحديدية الأوكرانية
إنه في غضون ساعة واحدة
تعرضت البنية التحتية للسكك الحديدية في خمسة أماكن
لضربات روسية ، كان أقصى الغرب
بالقرب من بلدة كراسناي ناتاليا روداك
كان يعمل في هذا المبنى المجاور
للمسارات عندما  سمعت انفجارات
[موسيقى]
من هذا الدفاع الجوي الجانبي أسقط
صاروخًا ثم صمت
الانفجار الثاني كان على هذا الجانب ،
رأينا دخانًا أسودًا ،
كيف كانت
صخب النوافذ عالية جدًا وأصيبنا بالذعر
كنا خائفين
من أن مكتب المحافظ أطلق هذا
مقطع فيديو يُظهر حريقًا ودخانًا كثيفًا بالقرب
من المسارات ، ويقولون إن
محطة فرعية كهربائية أصيبت على الرغم من أنه على الأرض
لم يُسمح لنا بالاقتراب
في عدة أماكن.  في جميع أنحاء
هذه المنطقة ، عثرت الشرطة والجيش على
ما يقولون إنها بقايا
صاروخ روسي ، هذا واحد منهم عبارة عن
كومة ملتوية من المعدن المتفحم المذاب ، يجدونها في
كل مكان
ما لم يعثروا عليه رغم أنه
حفرة كبيرة و  لذلك يعتقدون أن
هذا تم
إسقاطه في منطقة فنزويلا ، قال الحاكم هناك
إن غارتين منفصلتين قتلت
خمسة وأصابت 18. وقالت القيادة العسكرية الأوكرانية في منشور
على الإنترنت إن
روسيا تستهدف طرق إمداد السكك الحديدية الحيوية
من أجل تعطيل
شحنات الأسلحة من  أفادت الدول الشريكة لأوكرانيا على
الجانب الآخر من الحدود الروسية ،
أن حريقًا اندلع في منشأة لتخزين النفط
على الأراضي الروسية ،
ويقول المسؤولون الروس إن سبب الحريق غير
واضح ، لكنه يأتي بعد وقت قصير من
اتهام الكرملين لأوكرانيا بضرب
مستودع نفط روسي آخر في  مدينة
بيلغورود